ladies and gentlemen the armed conflict
in yemen is escalating more and more
with each passing day
for three weeks airstrikes have been
carried out there by the saudi-led
military coalition in other words yemen
is beside the civil war
in a state of international war
in a statement for march 27 unesco
director general inarina bukova urged
all parties involved in military
operation to preserve the yemeni culture
heritage
but how to protect culture heritage in
yemen
al qaeda housing rebels growing
islamization and increasing radicalism a
failed state a threat to the west these
are the headlines we meet when reading
about yemen today
the protection of culture heritage in
yemen is getting more and more difficult
if not even impossible
also the german archaeological institute
with its branch in sana since 1978
conducted feed research the last time in
spring 2011 whereas other projects like
capacity building measures for the
general organization of antiquities and
museum shortly called gohan
had to be stopped in yemen end of 2013.
yemen the ancient saudi arabia the land
of the queen of sheba and the former
arabia felix happy arabia
is among the oldest and most
multifaceted cultural landscape on the
arabian
peninsula its heritage looks back up in
millennia of years
yet in view of the political unrest
there today this heritage is being
forgotten more and more
nevertheless in addition to human
suffering insecurity and loss and
community life this crisis encroaches
upon the cultural heritage of yemen as
well which until now was used in
national dialogue and in the
self-identifying representation of the
state
however the lack of or no longer
effective mechanism of state control in
the different yemeni provinces have
meanwhile led to the increasing
destruction of its culture heritage
this destruction has secured through
illicit diggings plunder unauthorized
construction projects and growing
illegal trade in antiquities for example
this is reflected by an enormous
increasing number of south arabian
antiquities offered in auction houses
in order to pursue illegal trade in
culture goods the german ecological
institute is in close contact with the
yemeni antiquity authorities
and the german federal criminal police
office
furthermore reports about systematic
illegal excavation have increased even
before the present crisis these were
alarmingly active in regions in which
the authority of the central government
had little or no influence and now they
too have increasing with the spread of
anarchy throughout large areas of the
country
nevertheless too far and let us hope
that it will remain so there is no
indication of fanatical religious
motivated destruction of culture
artistic work like we saw before in the
panel in syria or in iraq
this i quote attacked
on the history eradication of culture by
religious fanatics will hopefully not
become a future model for yemen
the culture roots of yemen are seen
still
as starting not in the islamic past only
but even earlier in pre-islamic times
whether the queen of sheba the great dam
of marip or the rulers of himya empire
in the yemeni highlands who knew to
unite the country and spread their
authority over almost all of present-day
yemen
during our many excavations we never
experienced rejections or refusals quite
the opposite we met with much interest
and tolerance even marvel
nonetheless the culture heritage of
yemen and with this i mean the
pre-islamic as well as islamic legacy is
very threatened and stands in accurate
danger
the yemeni antiquity authorities and
also the general organization of the
preservation of historical cities
which is unfortunately not represented
today by dr naji
sorabi
as the goham and gaufy which aside from
his main offices in sana have branches
in all of the provinces is responsible
among other duties for pursuing and
obstructing these illegal activities to
protect and preserve the culture
heritage
and to impose counteractions
imperative for the successful operation
of these measures is the systematic
recording and documentation
following international guidelines of
archaeological sites and archaeological
material in collection and museums as
well as objects retrieve from illegal
context
nevertheless only a few members of the
gorham office possess a founded
knowledge of modern methods for
documenting culture heritage
the president of goa mohan
is well aware of this problem and very
engaged in seeking solutions
already in 2012 a program for further
education was initiated by the german
archaeological institute in sana
due to unstable conditions in yemen
however this undertaking had to be
prematurely discontinued
for this reason the german
archaeological institute with the
financial aid of the german federal
foreign office will conduct
a summer school let's say for employees
of gohan in berlin or an arabian third
country with secure conditions this year
parallel to this
a further project will be set up by us
the most important international
guidelines and measures for handling
culture material whose documentation and
digital archiving will be published
online and in the print version in
arabic in a form
of an advisory a handbook of best
practices in handling with culture
heritage
basically goham is well structured
and as far as person is concerned well
thought out
the central office assigned relatively
independently acting directors to every
province who were responsible for the
site as well as the museums located
there
the range of duties encompassed the
study protection preservation including
restoration and conservation of
archaeological sites as well as a
presentation of the movable and
unmovable culture material
the number of employees is relatively
large but still not enough
whereby most are concerned less with
archaeological work and function more as
guards
these guards stem from the traditional
clans and tribes in the region of the
sites and are chosen for this position
with the permission of the head of the
respective clan and tribe
on one hand here in lies one important
strength
of the system so the feeling of
responsibility for local culture
heritage is correspondently great yet on
the other hand this
traditional tribal structure has the
result that any influence on the part of
the central state authority is more or
less impossible
hence the attempt to nationalize an
archaeological site that is located
outside of an urban center almost never
succeeds
archaeological material found within a
tribal region usually remains in that
particular province mostly even in the
vicinity of the site in the tribal area
an example is the sarbane city of sava
province of marip where one storage
serves for keeping all fines of the area
and is guarded by tribal members
and still it's in
intact as i heard yesterday
the transference of the fines from this
facility to the province capital marip
located a mere 40 kilometers away
is as unthinkable as sending a few of
the fines to the national museum in sana
for this reason most provinces disposed
over at least one central provincial
museum as well as numerous site museums
the situation combined with the absence
of a central program in which sites and
fines are systematically recorded makes
an overview and control of museums
holding and of archaeological sites
including plunder theft and so on wholly
impossible
essential now is the creation of a
specific education courses and advanced
projects as well as technical support
for facilities in order to implement a
data recording system that is as
comprehensive as possible
including digital
photographic documentation if possible
3d
in order to document existing cultural
heritage and to identify objects in our
trade and also possible
looted goods
in the medium or maybe more long-term
education and the creation of an
unbiased culture historical
understanding in the yemeni society for
the history and regional culture
heritage are important elements for its
protection and preservation
the german ecological institute together
with this yemeni partners is attempting
to contribute to these efforts in all
areas and this is also an appeal to the
international community not forget to
forget yemen
the former happy arabia thank you very
much for your attention and thank you
for the organizer